in past videos we've thought about
whether segment lengths or angle
measures are preserved with a
transformation what we're now going to
think about is what is preserved with a
sequence of transformations and in
particular we're going to think about
angle measure
angle
measure
and segment lengths so if you're
transforming some type of a shape
segment
lengths so let's look at this first
example they say a sequence of
transformations is described below so we
first do a translation then we do a
reflection over a horizontal line pq
then we do a vertical stretch about pq
what is this going to do is this going
to preserve angle measures and is this
going to preserve segment lengths
well a translation is a rigid
transformation and so that will preserve
both angle measures and segment lengths
so after that angle measures and segment
lengths are still going to be the same
a reflection over a horizontal line pq
well a reflection is also a rigid
transformation and so we will continue
to preserve angle measure and segment
lengths
then they say a vertical stretch about p
q
well let's just think about what a
vertical stretch does so if i have some
triangle right over here
if i have some triangle
that looks like this it says triangle a
b c
and if you were to do a vertical stretch
what's going to happen well let's just
imagine that we take these sides and we
stretch them out so that we now have a
is over here or a prime i should say is
over there let's say that b prime
is now over here
this isn't going to be exact well what
just happened to my triangle
well the measure of angle c is for sure
going to be different now and my segment
lengths are for sure going to be
different now a prime c prime is going
to be different than ac in terms of
segment length so a vertical stretch if
we're talking about a stretch in general
this is going to preserve neither so
neither preserved
neither
preserved so in general if you're doing
rigid transformation after rigid
transformation you're going to preserve
both angles and segment lengths but if
you throw a stretch in there then
all bets are off you're not going to
preserve either of them let's do another
example
a sequence of transformations is
described below and so they give three
transformations so pause this video and
think about whether angle measures
segment lengths or
well well either both or neither or only
one of them be preserved
all right so first we have a rotation
about a point p that's a rigid
transformation it would preserve both
segment lengths and angle measures
then you have a translation which is
also a rigid transformation and so that
would preserve both again
then we have a rotation about point p so
once again another rigid transformation
so in this situation everything is going
to be preserved so both
angle measure
and
segment
length are going to be preserved in this
example
let's do one more example
so here once again we have a sequence of
transformations and so pause this video
again and see if you can figure out
whether angle measures segment lengths
both or neither are going to be
preserved
so the first transformation is a
dilation
so dilation is a non-rigid
transformation so segment lengths not
preserved segment lengths
not
preserved
and we've seen this in multiple videos
already but in a dilation angles are
preserved angles
preserved
so already we've lost our segment
lengths but we still got our angles then
we have a rotation about another point q
so this is a rigid transformation it
would preserve both but we've already
lost our segment lengths but angles are
going to continue to be preserved and
then finally a reflection which is still
a rigid transformation and it would
preserve both but once again our segment
lengths got lost through the dilation
but we will preserve continue to
preserve the angles so in this series of
after these three transformations the
only thing that's going to be preserved
are going to be your angles